だとか何とかとか思った瞬間で不善心種はもう生まれてるんだから
まあじゃあ初めまたやり直しという状態になるんです
ですから この後ろ見るんですね
いつでもみんな過去を見る
よくできるようになった
それは過去の考え方なの
過去を見るなと 前を見ていかなくちゃいけないんだから
それから大体このヴィタッカからちょっと成長して
ヴィチャーラのレベルでやっていて
あのすぐに何やっています？もう何も過去にできないとかね
知らないうちに眠気が出てきて
眠気にあの入ってしまったりとか
ということはありますけどね
そういうことじゃなくて
この積極的な確認じゃなくて
自然の確認の流れに入ったならば
それからもう言葉要りませんだからより明確に
より早く ものすごい素早く確認できるようになる
そういう言葉なしに確認すると
この無常の方向へ持っていけることはできますね
そこでまあヴィチャーラも
まあヴィチャーラあっても
まあ最終的にはもう無常体験できますけどね
どうしても言葉がなきゃできない鈍いというか
この人々もまたいるんですね
それはまあ性格の問題だからね
そう言ってことすごく遅い
とにかく遅い 言葉で頑張ってるんだから
そういう人々にお釈迦様は別々に説法していて
言葉ない世界ですぐ体験する人々にはまた別々に説法があったりとか
だから瞑想指導はそれなりにまたいろいろあるんです
それは性格分析のところであの出てきます
それもアビダンマの一つの分野なんです
性格の分析と それにそのその性格にどんな瞑想法がふさわしいかと
ですから 天才 生まれつき天才みたいな言葉ない人々っていうのは
まあそんな時間かかること何のもなく
もうもうなんのことない真理だから
すぐ発見する 言葉は事実やと思ってる人々は
まあかなりすごく苦労しなくちゃいけない
時間かけなくちゃいけない
だからヴィパッサナーではまあ頑張っていますよ
考えるな 音は音だと そこで止まれと言ってるのは
この大変な意味なんですよ
もう簡単単純なことを言ってるわけじゃなくてですね
言葉の世界からその人をね
すぐ強引に引っ張りたがっちゃうんですね
これ成長してもう天才になるまで
これ何千万年待てばいいかわからないんだから
それでも人は成長するという限り決まってはないんだから
だからまあ強引に引っ張ってもらうということでね
音は音ですと 音は音だから別に言葉じゃないんだから
耳に入るのは音であって
ある音というサブダというエネルギーなんで
ある波動なんです そこに言葉あるというバカがいるんですかね
それどう見てもバカバカしいよ
ただの音 体に触れるのはもう二つだけなんですね
パトリですか 硬さと温度
ただそれだけ ですから
それだけで確認して止まりなさいと
それともう言葉のこの森からもうすぐもう外へ出ることができるんです
だから森に迷ったら 迷った人はどうやってそれから出てくるならば
一番早い方法はどういう方法ですかね
一番早いのは空見ることですよ
空見たらどっちから来たかとかちゃんとあるんです
ただ 自分が村にいて森に入ったと
森は村の西にあるんだというぐらいは知ってるでしょうに
村があって西の方に森があったっていうことぐらいわかるでしょう
空を見たらどっち西かとかわかるんだから
そこ行けばいいんです
自分が来た道といかに変わっても関係ないんです
すぐ森から逃げ出られるんだから
絶対出られない人々はもうこちらから入って
こちらの左にこの木 この木は前を見たんだから
でも似てる木はいっぱいあるんだから
[笑い]あっちやってあの水たまりを飛んだんだから脱そうと
で 出てこない 出てくる場合もありますし
出てこられない場合もあります
そのためにはきちんと変えた順番で道を覚えていかなくちゃいけないんですね
ですから 言葉の世界に入ってる人は
そこから脱出するためにはものすごくもう
難しくて時間かかるというかね
森で出てくる早い方が空を見ることと
いうようなもので まあすぐこの事実に触れると
まあわかるようにはなります
まあそれはヴィタッカヴィチャーラなんですね
そこでヴィタッカヴィチャーラなどなどは生まれる心はまた別々で
ヴィ
タッコータワディパニャーサヴィンヤーナワッジタカーマーチャラチッテスチェワエーカダサスパタマジャーナチッテスチャパンチャパンニャーサチッテスウパッジャティ
そこでヴィタッカという
えっと 人という真相が考える言葉っていうことは
この まあ説明難しいんだ
ディパンチャヴィンヤーナという
あの 何て言いますか 十種類の心があります
どうやって訳るんですかね
五識 五識はセット二つあります
五識っていうのは あの
チャックヴィンヤーナ
ソートヴィンヤーナ チャックソートガーナヴィンガーナ
ジーヴァーカーヤという
眼耳鼻舌身という五つに識がつけて
それで五つなんです それはこの二つのセット二つあります
うーん まあそこら辺はもう思い出す以外方法ないんだけど
で 一つはこの 不戦審 不戦の時空と
もう一つは戦時空 だから随分昔説明しました
で その眼耳鼻舌身の心は十種類ありますよと覚えといた方がいいし
その十種類にはヴィタッカはないんです
目で見えるだけ そこで考えることはないんです
目でただ見えるだけ 耳で聞くだけ
別に聞くということは耳に生まれるわけないんです
聞かなくちゃとかね それは胃の働きで耳にはただ音さえあればもう聞いてるんです
目には見える形あるならばもう見ているんですね
何の意志もなくても見える
舌に何か触れるものあれば
すぐ味は知ってますよ
ということだから 眼耳鼻舌身のこの十種類の心にはない
それにおいて この大体欲界身には全部生まれますが
[笑い]そこでこの 禅定の心は特別なカテゴリーに分けるんです
で 禅定は第一 二 三 四 四
五とまた五つあります
それから無色界の四つあります
その四つの第五の禅定だと言ったりもします
とにかくそこに心は全部ここなすですね
それに出世間心も第一
二 三 四禅定に基づいて出世間心生まれるということで
そこからはまた八種類かな
得られるんですけど ちょっと離れますか
と まあ出世間心はどうしても八があります
その八は五つの禅定に入れると八掛ける五で四十になるんです
そこで第一禅定の第一禅定に基づいた出世間心は預度預果とかに分けちゃうと
えーと 何言おうとしてるんですかね
私も 日本語で言うのは難しいです
全部これからパーリ語だけにするんだったらモサササと説明できますけど
ソーターパッティ マッガパッラ
二つありますね 預度預果
そこはソーターパッティ
預度の心が五つありますし
預果の心は五つあります
そういう風なもので 八掛ける五四十で
で 僕は言いたがっているのは
この第一禅定は十一番ありますよということなんです
第一禅定は第一禅定の禅定心と位熟心とキリェチットは何でした？有為作心と三つあります
第一禅定は三つ 瞑想に入っちゃうと禅定に入っちゃうと禅定心
で 瞑想の結果として生まれる心はもう位熟心
第一禅定の位熟心 で 阿羅漢が第一禅定に入ったら第一禅定の有為作心
ただ機能だけ 結果がない
善悪に関係ないと それで第一禅定の心は三つ
出世間心の第一禅定の心が八
預度預果と一来度一来果と不還道不還果と阿羅漢道阿羅漢果と
そこで八あります 第一禅定の出世間心
その八とこの三つは十一になります
その差は説明しましたね
ただ瞑想だけする サマーディ瞑想ですか
サマーディ瞑想だけするとどうせ禅定は生まれるんです
どんな人にでも それは関係なく生まれるんです
そこでサマタ瞑想もと一緒にヴィパッサナー瞑想すると
あるいはサマタ瞑想して第一禅定を得る
得てからヴィパッサナー瞑想する
あるいは両方一緒にする
それはまあ どれほどヴィパッサナー瞑想
サマタ瞑想の場合は まあ基本的にはそれほど差がないんだからね
で 第一禅定に入った人がヴィパッサナー瞑想をして悟るところまで行ったならば
その人には出世間心は八も生まれるんですね
その出世間心八も第一禅定の次元で出世間心が生まれたことだから
第一禅定の預度 第一禅定の預果
第一禅定の不還道 第一禅定の不還果
第一禅定の一来度や第一禅定の一来果
第一禅定の阿羅漢道 第一禅定の阿羅漢果と言うんです
その差ですね だから出世間心は八で取るか四十で取るかとどっちか
禅定だけ作ってそれで終わる人々の場合は
まあ別に第一禅定の善心と意熟心二つしかないんです
禅定に初めて入る場合は善心と言うんですね
第一禅定の善心 いいことをしました
そこでその人 第一禅定に入ってサマーディ状態に入って楽にいると
禅定の結果が味わってるんですね
その場合は第一禅定の意熟心が生まれてるんです
が アビダンマでは意熟心だとそれでも言わないみたい
で アビダンマで言うのはこういうこと
その第一禅定の人が死ぬと
死んだら確実に梵天に生まれる
梵天というのは第一禅定にふさわしい次元に生まれる
なぜ梵天かということは
禅定というのは欲から離れないと生まれないんです
いくら瞑想しても欲に未練がある限り禅定は生まれません
欲 この場合は欲っていうのはむさぼりではなくて
眼耳鼻舌身の世界に未練があるということ
見るもの 聞くもの 味わうもの
嗅ぐもの 体に触れるものに未練があると
絶対その次元を乗り越えられない
体の次元は乗り越えられない
そこで体には依存しないと
体は関係ないと 未練がなくなったら欲から離れると言うんです
そこで初めて心は統一するんです
体に頼ってないんだから
その状態に第一禅定というんです
ですから その人は亡くなって生まれる時も
見るもの 聞くもの 味わうものに依存しない次元に生まれ変わらなくちゃいけない
ですから 天国には生まれないんだと
天国っていうのは欲は欲の世界
思い存分楽しめる次元なんですね
聞いて楽しむ 見て楽しむと
その刺激ですね 聞いて
見て 味わって 触って 触れて
楽しめる次元 天国と言うんです
だから人間の次元とはそれほど変わりはない
人間と神々はそんなに差がない
ただ 人間はこの楽しみさというのはわずかしか味わえない
1ヶ月間仕事をして給料をもらう
もらう喜びは瞬間で お金が消えるのは随分早く消えてしまうと
料理を作るためにはもう 1時間
2時間かかるんだけど
たまにもっと時間かかる場合があります
食べる時はもうちょっと五分で終わっちゃう
ですから 楽しみの時間はほんのわずかで
苦しみの時間は随分長いんです
それは人間の次元です
それは逆になって 天界っていうのは楽しみの次元の方が随分時間長くて
苦しみの時間は少ない
天国でもですね まあそれぐらいの差で
そんな大した高次元ではないんです
で 禅定を作った人はその世界には生まれないんですね
その次元に梵天と呼ぶんです
で 梵天で生まれる時は
その人の心は人間で修行した結果だから
成熟心というんです ですから
この人間の性格は変わらないんですね
我々生まれの瞬間で得た心のエネルギーは
もうなかなか死ぬまでそれで頑張らなくちゃいけないんですね
そういう感じで 例えばいい
すごい強い心で生まれたら
それからどんなアホなことをしたっても
人間で成長できるし 弱い心で生まれた人は
その弱みをずっと引きずっていくんですね
心の弱みっていうのは
それ変わらない 心の基本エネルギーだからね
で 梵天で基本的な心のエネルギーは第一禅定だから
ずっと物質に依存しないで生活はできるというぐらいで
梵天の次元が出てくる
で この第一禅定ではかなり積極的に瞑想しなきゃ
この集中力は生まれてこない
瞑想のことを説明すると
例えば何か対象を取って
マントラでもいいし 何か目で見る何かでもいいし
曼荼羅でも何でもいいんだけど
何かを取ってそれに集中して集中して
積極的に全てのものはカットして集中して
心集中することだけ仕事にする
そうすると どんどんどんどん他の世の中のことは面白くなくなっちゃうんです
そのものにだけ集中することはもう面白くなってきて
それから喜びを感じるようになってくる
そこで心からはもう全部この眼耳鼻舌身に頼ることはいいと
という状態になって この瞑想対象だけ絞ってくる状態があるんですね
一体になる状態 それは第一禅定という
それでもその人の頭ではちゃんともう思考は働いています
第一禅定 思考がなくても
このヴィパッサナー料理ものすごく明確ですけど
この集中力は流れていると
それは第番目の禅定 アビダンマの第番目の禅定というのは
何も考えない状態でも統一性がある
お経では第番目のアビダンマは第番目
番目の禅定はさらにこの喜びだけ生まれてきて
喜びに集中していられると
対象はなしと 第番目の第番目の禅定っていうのは
喜びもなくなって 遮の状態で集中のレベルを保つことはできると
心の成長の次元なんですね
経験としてはただ一つになっているような感じなんです
自分というもう実感はない
眼耳鼻舌身にも全然興味は何もない
一つになっていると そういうふうな状態なんですね
この梵我一如状態だというのは
だから禅定を得た人は
だからヒンドゥー教での宗教を悟ったという状態は
仏教ではそれは禅定状態だと言っているんです
無色界ではもうさらに進みますからね
無色界っていうのは形も消えちゃう
心の波動 まあそういう説明ずっとしましたからね
繰り返す必要はないし
で ヴィタッカという 神通は第一禅定にはあります
第一禅定は種類があります
それだけ それから欲界心はがあります
あるんだけど そこにを引く
あの 眼耳鼻舌身のを引きたらそこで残ります
そのとこのの心を足したところで
その心には神通があるんだ
このリスト見るとなんでしょうかね
リストでは リストではこの雑深経の神通という言葉の下を見ると
どんな心に全部入っているかということは見えてきますね
[背景音楽]この瞋抜けてるところはこの不善依止心七つありますけど
そこで一から五書いてますね
それから善依止心八ありますね
そこで一から五ありますね
その心だけは教義指針章だけ
そこで色界の一番目で瞋が終わるんですね
で 出世間心は四十ありまして
そこは全部八八と計算します
で 所詮所詮にまた瞋が入ってるんです
ですから そこで八がある
心は八種類 全部数えてみれば
出てくるだろうと思います
そんなふうなことで じゃあこちらで我々には何の役に立つかって問題も出てきますけどね
それを知ったんだからといって
そこで思惟がどんな心に生まれ
生まれるかというと  Ekādasas dutiyajjhāna cittesu
そこで瞋が生まれる すべての心にまた十一足すんです
第二禅定もつけるんです
そこで十一だから で 六十六の心に思惟が生まれると
次にアディモッカ この六つだけで難しいな
すっごくややこしくて難しいな
アディモッカは日本語で何と言いますか
ん 正解 まあ正解 他の言葉は実は言ったでしょうかね
アディモッカ 正解っていうのはちょっと難しいね
アディモッカの意味はこの正解ではなくてね
この見るものにこの釘を打ったようにこの引っかかってる意味なんですね
対象に引っかかるって意味なんです
集中力でもないんです
集中力とは似ていますけどね
で 認識する対象に引っかかる
引っかかってないとそこをずっと集中力もできませんね
その引っかかる働きが正解と言うんです
アディモッカと言うんです
で 正解という漢字はもう完全に間違ってます
それはもうあの言葉 パーリ語の言葉を見て
それをサンスクリット語にして
それから漢文にしましたから
そういう感じになっているんです
これはパーリ語の言葉はサンスクリット語はもともと古いんだから
パーリ語はサンスクリット語に入れちゃう
また戻しちゃうと変になるんです
いわゆるパーリ語っていうのは
ある一つの地方の言葉なんです
お釈迦様はサンスクリット語は誰も喋って誰の母国語でもないんです
あれはなんて言いますか
文学の言葉 ヨーロッパのラテン語みたいに勉強するとき
本を書くときサンスクリット語を使う
ヨーロッパでもラテン語を使っていましたし
喋るときは自分の言葉で喋っていたんです
ドイツ語やら英語やら色んな言葉
本を書くときはラテン語
大学で儒教はラテン語で昔
インドはまあほとんど今でもサンスクリット語はみんな使っている
みんな知ってるんだけど
サンスクリット語で日常会話なんかはしません
そのその地方で自分の言葉ありました
ですから お釈迦様は特別な学問の言葉で講演説法したりするのは意味がないんだと
人間 人間の即合で方言というかね
その方言でお話をしていたんですね
そこでパーリ語の経典は残りましたし
他の言葉で喋ったものは残ってないんですね
それはまあ 私たちは分かりません
知りませんだから 我々はパーリ語の伝統でしたから
それはちゃんと守りましたし
他の言葉で喋ったお経を真面目に守ってたお坊さんたちがいたならば
それをその人々の責任でね
残すことはそうやってないんだから
それは知りません ですから
今現に世の中でパーリ語の経典だけは完全に残している
一つも欠けることなく
だからとお釈迦様はパーリ語だけ使ったわけじゃないんです
例えば法句経なんかは他の言葉でも見つかってるんですね
パーリ語でない他の言葉でも
それはもう短いことだから
誰か誰か覚えておいたりとかね
まあ書いたりとかして見つかって
このトルファンですか
トルファン 日本語でトンゴ
まあそういう砂漠の中
あっちこっちから見つかってはいます
で パーリ語のこの地方の言葉はまた逆にこの学問の言葉に入れちゃうと
ですから仏教サンスクリット語はパーリ語よりは時代的には遅い
サンスクリット語だからといって古いわけじゃないんです
サンスクリット語は古い
それはもう問題なし でもブッディストサンスクリットは古くない
パーリ語の方が古い それで結構学者の間ではかなり誤解したり
サンスクリットでやるんだからとか
だから何ですかって サンスクリット語だったって
それはもうもともとお釈迦様がサンスクリット語で教えたわけじゃないんだから
後でサンスクリット語にしたんだから
漢文になっているのは全部サンスクリット語が元になった経典なんですね
ですから 学問的に言うならば
パーリ語の経典は古いんですけど
学者はそう認めたくないんです
日本の学者は サンスクリット
漢文で似ているものがあったら
すぐそこは正しくて パーリ語のものは間違っているとすぐ言うんです
中村先生もそう言うんです
もうものすごい決まっていて
まあたまに正しく場合もありますけど
全く正しくない場合もあります
それはそれで置いておいて
アディモクはサンスクリット語にしちゃうとアディモクシャになるんです
モクシャは解脱でアディはスピーリアという意味になって
ですから正解になっちゃうんです
でもその意味はパーティモクシャというこのお坊さんたちの戒律にも同じこと言葉なんです
お坊さんたちの戒律にはパーティモクシャと書いて
あれは日本訳何でしたっけ
パラダイモクシャとかなんとかという
これは音だけなんですけど
なんとかという それまた解脱という訳をしているので解脱じゃないんです
あれは逆なんです 意味は
いわゆるパーティモクシャというのは戒律ですけど
で それで何とか解脱と言ったら意味がないんです
戒律を守ることは結局自由がなくなることなんですよ
縛られることなんです
ですから ある生き方を決めて
そこにこの通りにしなさいと
もうそれ以上はもういけないんですね
行動 行動範囲はもうきちんと決まっちゃう
その意味でパーティモクシャと
パーティっていうのは完全に丸くもう押さえておいたと
それ以上はもう喋ることは決まっていて
体の行動決まっていて
もう衣を着ることを決まっていてとか
もう何から何までもう決まっていると
自由になったわけじゃないんですよ
逆に束縛されたわけなんです
日本語ではもうそれも解脱と
なんとか解脱と日本訳するんですね
日本語ではなくて漢文ではね
それでまあいろんな問題が出てきたり
訳が間違ったんだから
それから仏教学も全部もう間違ってる道に行ってしまっちゃいます
その二つは一番大きなポイントで
そこでアディモッカっていうのは生解ではなくて
もうこれ脱は入れてないんだけどね
モッカだから生解脱ではなくて
結局逆の意味 その釘で打たれたように対象に引っかかったと
対象に引っかかったんだから
その対象は認識する で
ここでいくら私の話を聞いていても
いきなり外からすごい音が来たらそこに引っかかっちゃうでしょうに
それを聞いてるんです
私の話を聞かない そういう働きアディモッカなんです
ですから 生解の反対の言葉あればいいんですけど
生は別に入れても解ではなくても
他の 結ぶというような感じがありますね
何て言いますか 解の反対
結 ですから 生結と言った方がいいかもしれませんし
それにも引っかかったと
それは別にもうそんなに浅学の意味じゃないんです
誰でもどんな人でも まあ何か聞こうとすると
それには引っかかっている
何か見ようとするとそれに引っかかっているんです
認識が だからそれ見られるし
で 今思い出した例えなんだけど
昔の映画っていうのは音はなかったんですね
一番最初 映像だけ見てみんな楽しかったんです
それだけで引っかかったんです
その でもどんどん見ていると
あまりこのアディモッカですか
あまり働かなくなっちゃうんですね
面白くないんだから それで映像はスクリーンに映るんだけど
そこに誰かがいて バイオリンを弾いたり
そのダイアログですか
あのしゃべるんですね
それで あ これは前より面白いんだと
ですから 昔の映画館にスクリーンがあって
そこにまた人が音楽やってる人々と喋る人々が並んでちゃんと待ってるんです
それで映画始めたら向こうはちゃんと音楽
もうバイオリン弾いたり
音楽を奏でたり それでもう何て言いますか
女優さん 俳優さんが出たら
その人と喋ることはこちらで人間が喋っていると
それまた好かれますからね
もっと簡単な便利な方法はないかと思ったところで
まあそこから映像から音が出るようにと進んでいったでしょうに
それはこの このアディモッカが生まれてくると
そこを人々は見てくれると
認識してくれると それどんどんどんどん
さらにさらに進むでしょ
とにかくこの興味を引こうということなんです
それで今の映画っていうのは
スクリーンは巨大で 昔は小さなスクリーンで良かったのに
そこで音はそんなもんじゃないんです
今は ものすごいサラウンドシステムとドルビーステレオシステムとデジタル音声とかいろいろなことをして
で 馬がこっちの右から左に走っていっちゃうと
スクリーンでちゃんと音を右から聞こえてきて
左に行って左で消えていくんですね
そういう風に このとにかく臨場感となんとかという言葉あるんだけど
そういう風にこの面白さですか
それはアディモッカなんです
引っかかる ということに
ですから アディモッカっていうのはどんな心にもあるんです
興味ないと認識が生まれません
まあ興味といえば大きな言葉だから
仏教専門アビダンマ専門用語としてはまあどうかわかりませんだけど
アディモッカの証言の代わりに興味と書いてあっても
僕はあんまり気にしませんだけど
興味 でもいいんです アディモッカはどちらに生まれますかというと
ヴィチキッチャー・サハガタ・ワッジタ・チッテーサ
あの10種類のこの心には何も生まれません
それを覚えておいてください
眼耳鼻舌身では何もなくても認識する
興味あってもなくても
人が体を触ったら知ってるでしょうに
あのこの人について興味がない
だからといってその人を体を触って知らないということはないでしょうに
この絵には興味がないと言っても見えないんですかね
見えるんだからね ですから
何の心生もなくても今日一切心生七つだけなんですね
このパンチャニ냐ーナ二つ
眼耳鼻舌身の10種類には
ここでその10とヴィチキッチャー
疑の心 ヴィチキッチャー・サハガタ・チッタンというのは
この あの貪瞋瞋 瞋恨心ともう一つありましたっけ？痴根心
二つあった これ12の不善心の中に
痴の無知の心二つあった
その中に一つあります
ヴィチキッチャー・サハガタ
疑がある心だと その心にはアディモッカがないんだと
というと なんかわかる可能性あります
このヴィチキッチャーっていうのは
疑といってもいろんなことを真剣に疑うことではないんです
それいろんなことを疑ってみることはすごい智慧の道なんです
バカみてえなこと何でも大のみするのはもうもう無知そのものだから
そうかそうか そうかなという感じで当たっているのは智慧の道であって
それも我々のそこの俗世間では疑
この人疑い深いねとかもう怒ったりもしますね
言うこと信じてくれないと
でもその人こそ正しいんですよ
その人はこれはいいやと言うと
もうそれはもう信頼できるし
疑い深い人だから ですから
その世の中にある疑いという意味じゃないんですね
仏教で言う疑というのは
世の中にある一般的にある疑いは仏教ではありがたく
それは素晴らしいこと
信仰するなと 始まるんだから
お釈迦様こう言うんだから
私が言うんだからといって信じるなと
私はブッダである ブッダ様だから信じます
常人じゃない 信じるなと
疑えと ですから それはもう最高ないい心で
疑いなければね 科学もないでしょうに
ですから 聖書なんかの文化では
人間のそういう道徳のを禁じられているんですね
疑うなかれと 信じなさいと
神の言葉だと それですごいひどい目に遭います
それはこのイスラム文化ではもうずっと見えるんです
キリスト教は科学が現れたところでもう壊れたんだから
もう問題もそれほどないんだけど
イスラム教の世界ではいまだに自分たちの聖書こそ神の言葉で
それは唯一なもので それには逆らうなと徹底的に従えという状態にいるんだから
いまだにこの石油あるんだから
金があるだけであって
人は成長しない 戦争ばっかり戦いと
もうお互いに殺し合いばっかりやっていて
かわいそうに生きているんですね
そこで面白いことは テレビでこのアフガニスタンのいろんな問題出るでしょ
みんなあのあれ でっかいあれ
何て言うんですか あのロケット弾の薄い道具ありますね
あれを持って それにロケットを入れてスイッチを入れて
アッラーフアッバスって言ってスイッチ入れるんです
で 何やってるんです？この連中が
もし自分がアッラーの言葉をちゃんと信じているならば
自分が正しくアッラーが守ってくるならば
何のために相手を殺すんですかね
そこでこちら私こそアッラーを信じているんだと言ったって
向こうに鉄砲を撃ったっても
こっちが勝ってるかって
そうでもないんです どちらも勝ってないし
向こうがアッラーアッバスって
もうバカバカしくてね
あるいは逆にアッラー守ってくれないんだから
俺の土地は俺たちの手に守らなくちゃって言って
あと